i'm in philadelphia we're filming
untouchable okay um and i had a day off
so i decided to go to the sixers game
james harden is playing in the game and
the whole game the whole first quarter
he's just he's off and i was like you
know why you off because you're in my
city your beard stinks i hate you i was
like i hate your calves i told him i
said i think you got i think you got
butt shots i was saying a bunch of stuff
here and he got mad he said he said
remember all this he said i'm about to
cook you i said you gonna cook me or put
me in a pot because i'm ready to be
cooked
we're talking like he's i don't even
know why he's paying me this much
attention like
at some point i was like james is very
unprofessional on your behalf
you're not even supposed to be talking
to me
james went on to score 55 points and
here's the bad part they beat us by 30.
and with like a minute left he was
dribbling the ball and staying in the
half court and he was just staring at me
he goes
he goes tell your team what you did to
him and i said
i said you keep your mouth shut
let me tell you patrice came out to la
right so patrice comes out right first
of all let me tell you what patrice does
but she stays in my apartment right i'm
in a two-bedroom apartment uh at the
time i'm married uh so i'm like you know
chase you can stay with us it's no big
deal i put patrice in the guest room
right so one day i come home i'm gonna
give you guys the full fledge i don't
give a [ __ ] patrice [ __ ] him he could
give me [ __ ] later so i come home right
it's quiet i don't i don't hear anything
in the room so i'm like patrice you here
because you know the rental car was in
the garage i don't know i guess not i go
in the back
the computer's on patrice is in front of
the computer
i swear to god i cannot make this up
there's just some baby oil
patrice is big so i can't see it from
the computer he's got the he's got the
headphones on
attaching the computer right so there's
porn so patrice is [ __ ] like his his
his i guess he's got his dick out the
boxer hole
[Laughter]
he didn't want to
so i go
the arm i see the arm working right so
oh please so my wife she's about to come
in and i bet no no no wait wait wait
wait i might portray you can't hear me
cuz got the [ __ ] headphones on so i
smack i smacked the headphones off his
head i said i say stupid what you
beating your dick in the [ __ ] office
he's like
he's saying is your wife here so like
put hey man just cut the [ __ ] off
patrice
you know his back was so big so i
couldn't i couldn't see anything grace
he's like just get out man i'll be dead
in a second literally this is just worse
i'm not gonna be done with himself in
your [ __ ] office so i leave this is
this what makes patrice retreat but
she's coming out of liver masters he
said look
look guys there's nothing to say to
really make that situation better
uh it is what it is uh it happened
uh so let's just let's just forget about
it
okay uh biggest reality i've had i'm in
vegas right i'm with an athlete friend
of mine and yo you know ask me to make a
lot of money so we're there we're
hanging out keep in mind he makes more
money than me jay so i'm trying to keep
up with him sure whatever he does i'm
trying to do it okay so we go to a club
he got a table so i got a table he was
like hey but we together i said so what
i got money too i want my own
that's what i told him i'm gonna spend
my own money i'm a man despite my size
right i'm grown okay so
we get there he got bottles i wanted to
get boxed
yeah you know he had women come i didn't
have no women but at the time i was with
my aunt
it was my aunt's birthday you had your
aunt with me
it was her birthday right now uh i got
the bill i'm not gonna lie i didn't like
it you have you ever get a bill so high
you try to put it in the light like it's
gonna change right
it didn't change
nothing changed it was what it was
i had to talk to myself i said i said
kevin you know what just pay the bill go
to your room go to sleep so
i go to my room i go to sleep and here's
why i don't go out with athletes no more
the next morning
i wake up my friend i was with he called
me right he was like kev last night was
crazy i said yo i had a ball he said
well guess what we're gonna do the same
thing again tonight and i was like you
know i can't i can't go twice because
the weight of my bank account is set up
like you you ever no no
you ever start explaining your financial
situation to people for no reason at all
i said i would go but the way my account
is set up i gotta i got a checking in
the savings but all the money is in my
savings yeah so i gotta i gotta switch
it to the check-in but it takes three
business days
at this at this point in time that's all
and it's true yeah two steps jay it's
two stories out of you have you got a
lot of celebrity friends you hang out i
got celebrity friends but the same thing
i don't i don't deal with those guys i
don't deal with celebrities either i've
had once again reality checks you know
uh mckay pfeiffer i don't know if you
guys know macau oh sure yeah i'm a top
five terrific actor a great actor yeah
good friend of mine okay this is the
biggest reality check i've ever hit with
my life makai calls me he says kev my
son's birthday party is saturday he said
you want to come to the party i said
cool he said bring your daughter that's
why i'm inviting you i said all right i
get there it's at disneyland him and his
son are out front he got his son hand i
don't see nobody else at the park right
so i'm like dude i thought you said it
was a party he said it is it's just us i
brought the park out for the day
and i said okay what you mean you bought
the park out like like it's still people
in the park he said no it's just us like
we got it for like eight hours
um so i said you know before i go in did
you pay for this already are you looking
for help because i'm not here
no no i'm serious i'm not
i'm not in a position where i can help
you because the weight of my the weight
of my bank account
i got to check into the savings but all
my
[Applause]
you know i know dwyane wade he uh he's a
friend of yours yes he was he was
talking about you uh dwyane wade is
another good friend of mine wayne tried
to mess up my life dwayne he didn't no
no dwayne dwayne tried to make me buy a
boat i don't even have a house i said
hey man
i told him
i told him that i said hey i don't have
a house i don't think this is a good
purchase he's like you should just get
it i was like no i would but the way to
my bank account is set up
i don't want to be on the phone that
long
i want to ask you everybody take a look
at this video and we're going to ask you
to kind of narrate what was happening
take a look at this video
[Applause]
first of all first of all i know it
looks bad with me running into the
camera okay
uh let me explain y'all what's going on
all right it was a um it was puffy's
party all right puff had a party uh he's
calling me said kev can you host a party
with me i said yeah dude that's how i do
it i said i'm in new york so he said
look we create this little sexy scene in
the bathroom it's gonna be girls in the
tub
you trey songz fabulous like it's nice
it's gonna look like it's the place to
be we're gonna use streaming that's all
that's gonna be hot so get up there i'm
hosting you know first of all i'm a sex
symbol okay so
i'm up there i'm up there and i'm
hosting you know i'm i'm promoting the
party i'm like yeah man this is a nice
event you see we up here in the tub i
hear trey songz behind me first of all
if somebody here is on fire it's a panic
you know it's a yellow yo yo your hair
it should be crazy you would have
thought trey was singing this is all i
heard i heard yo your hair's on fire
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh because like literally like the flame
like george the
like
the flame grew like it was like it was
like somebody threw gasoline on it like
so when i saw i was like ow ow
so my first instinct was to save myself
because
you know at the end of the day
it's the truth
at the end of the day i don't i don't
want to die you know i don't know if you
guys know weaves are the most flammable
thing
a weed if there would have been another
girl next to a weed that thing would
have caught faster than the forest fire
so i said so i just said let me say it
myself now to camera i run i'm like did
you get that on tape
only reason why i said that is because i
didn't really get to see the whole thing
so i wanted to
i want to see it over again for myself
as reasons all right let's take a look
at it one more time everybody
let's see it
[Applause]
tell you one of the worst things that
happened to me okay uh i'm having like a
phenomenal shoe for those people that
play blackjack a shoe is uh you know a
deck of cards and you're going through
it and you know it's just going great
i'm hot and there's a hand
where i get like two eights and i bet
you know i bet a uh ridiculous amount of
money on the hand and i'm like all right
well i gotta split that you know i'm i'm
talking too much what does the dealer
have when uh the dealer had a sick
showing oh shots i never forget this uh
and i got two eights and i'm like oh i
gotta split that so i split em and i get
another eight and i was like oh hey
scared money don't make no money uh all
right all right let's go
i'm so excited i split them i give me no
no split that one too another eight four
eights out there i just split them all
at this point little piece of poop came
out my butt at this point
at this point i'm extremely i'm
extremely nervous because i've never
seen anything like this but it's people
around so i'm trying to play it cool i'm
like hey hey all right okay all right
all right what now what we gotta do now
hit that hit the first one a three come
out
the dealer looks at me she's like you
gotta double down i was like
yeah
yeah
i know i know i gotta do that
i gotta double down on that let's go
ahead and double down she said you wanna
see it face up or down i don't want to
see it
she put it down the next one comes out
it's a two so now i got a 10 she goes oh
my god got a double tail again
at this point my palms are sweating at
this point
i said i don't want to see it face down
okay the next car comes out i get a 10
so i got 18 on the last one i had
another 10. the dealer had a six showing
okay all right here we go it's go time
the dealer turns over the card
underneath it in slow motion it was i
saw it it was a five i said
i said you you got to be
oh
not like this
not like this
i'm like go slow go slow go slow
dealers you know dealers are fast to the
point where you can't count like you
haven't you ever tried to add it up but
you don't know where you're at so so i
know it's a five out there right she had
the five
real fast it was a three i was like oh
oh oh what's that what's that she's like
are you ready i said no no count that
what is that what is that okay all right
all right you got 14. all right go slow
go slow
real fast ace
eight oh my god what's going on what you
got
15.
like slow motion i've never seen
anything like it in my life real fast
what 6 21. she took the money
look she
she didn't even look me in the eye she
said
i just sat there i kept counting it i
was like hold on wait wait hold on
eleven plus three that's the 14. you got
an ace ace
that puts you all right right there i
think you got to
hold on wait a minute wait a second all
right
what i have what are these what do i
have
lift all that up that's nothing or this
ain't nothing none of this is nothing
huh
here's what pissed me off there's a guy
behind me he goes
man that's crazy
[Music]
[Music]
people i suffered a very serious injury
this weekend yeah in disney world i was
with my kids jay and i uh i took my kids
tubing and i know it doesn't sound like
it's that that's serious at first but i
was on the tube with my kids and the guy
goes hey man for adults you know we can
speed this thing up right i'm a
daredevil you know that okay i'm a thug
jay uh my background speaks for itself
i've been to jail listen what i'm saying
so we get off of the tube i'm like yeah
i want to do it so he's got me and my
brother we both get on set for twos
speed boat starts pulling at 70 miles
per hour i'm not lying okay we hit a
wave right now because i'm so small
because of my height i'm aerodynamic not
on purpose
not on purpose but we hit the wave bow i
shoot up in the air now i was scared at
first but then in my mind i started
thinking like oh i'ma stick it like i'm
gonna come down
and people are watching they're going
like oh this is probably what kevin hart
does on the side so i was like okay
so i came down right but i'm staring the
tube as i'm coming down i land now you
know water is water's hard like you know
if you hit it hard it's like concrete so
i smacked the water with the tube right
i don't know i'm hurt at the time i hear
everybody on the boat they're like oh my
god kevin it was sounding just like that
they're like
it was like oh my god kevin
yeah these are all white people on the
boat no no
no
[Applause]
it was like the instructor and my kids
they were like oh my god kevin so
i came down now when i came down i hit
the i hit the tube and i bounced off
into the water yeah i'm thinking i'm
still fine i go to swim like literally
with this stroke i go to take a swat a
stroke but this shoulder had popped out
of socket
i just thought that something i i
thought that
like you know i don't know who's had
this okay to show or not but if it's
this okay you literally had you don't
have that much feeling at the bottom so
i was like oh my arm must be caught on
the tube
that's the only reason it's not coming
back up so
so once i saw i couldn't get it up this
is when i started to panic a little bit
i didn't cry but you probably would have
thought that that's what it was
so like at this point in time i'm
flagging a guy because i want help i'm
like
this this idiot this jackass is giving
me a thumbs up you did it i'm like no no
i can't move it
they come they get me out the water and
uh my brother was like oh man he said
dude i could see your shoulder and like
you know you're fine until you see it
like once i saw it like it's just how
remember when you had your jammed toe
that time
you remember right remember
you were fine someone was like shaq you
jammed your toe you like uh
[Applause]
it was the same thing it was the same
thing so i saw it i panicked i lied to
you not i passed out like because i saw
my shoulder out the socket he was like
you're going to be all right and i was
like too late i'm going
it was over i woke up in the hospital it
was popped back in i tell you i tell you
a funny [ __ ] on yourself story no this
isn't to be the guy with the [ __ ] jokes
uh steven seagal right
steve is a goal
uh i'm doing uh that's another movie
so what are you teaching
how to do no this is this is going to
kill you i promise you it's going to
kill you so we're doing uh we're doing
ride along two cube accidentally punched
one of the stunt guys right in the nose
who's cube ice cube another i gotta
introduce you
he punches the stunt guy in the nose
stunt guy's nose starts bleeding q is
apologetic yo man i'm so sorry god i'm
i'm sorry i think no no man it's okay
like at least you're nice you know like
i know that it wasn't intentional we've
worked with people in the past that have
been just dicks right so he's like who
i'm like who else he's like well was a
girl you know he used to really get
shots in you know in these scenes so got
to a point where we had to come to our
boss you know the stunt coordinator we
were like hey man steven's really
hitting us like can you kind of tell him
to sound like he's lied down his wife
said
can you tell steve to relax a little bit
so stephen found out that one of the
guys was like a black belt in judo like
a a serious black belt so stephen comes
up to the guy he's like hey
put me in your best hold i bet you i can
get out of it and he's like i can't do
that you know you you're my boss i can't
do that to you he's like
put me in your best hole
he looks at his balls because stephen
was being a dick the guy said go ahead
do it
choke steven puts him in a chokehold all
right
stephen's struggling his feet his feet
squaming
searching for balance he can't it's like
he's losing air a little bit but you
know the you got to tap out well you
don't want anymore so
while you're here
all you hear is
[Music]
he taps out he taps out
it goes good good old and he's just he
belongs
to the bathroom he he comes out
smells like [ __ ] everywhere
the guy
choked the [ __ ] out of students at all
for death
but literally
what level did you get to as far as
basketball goes did you play high school
basketball uh
okay we being honest like because yeah
cause you can find footage so i don't
know how far i can lie okay uh
all right listen i played i played high
school basketball i played four years of
varsity but it wasn't it wasn't easy
okay um i wanted to play
real bad this is all i wanted to do my
mom she didn't want me to try out
because my school was like two hours
from my house we had to catch public
transportation and the tryouts for the
basketball team was at 6 00 a.m this is
a true story and my mom was like you're
not leaving our house at 4am to go try
out for a basketball team there's all
types of crazy people out here i'm not
sending my son on public transportation
at that time i was like mom but this is
the tryouts like i want to be on the
team it's going to get be on team she's
like no not going to happen so because
i'm such a genius i decided to take all
the clocks in the house
and set all of the clocks forward so
when it was oh i set it forward
when it was really 4 a.m i set the
clocks to say 6 a.m that's the time i
was leaving so like i woke my mom up and
everything like it was time for work i
got to get up she was like it's still
dark out what's going on today
i don't know but we got to get up out of
here
vcrs clocks her watches everything i set
every clock in the house and i made it
to tryouts i tried out and i was happy
my plan worked and midway through the
day i remember being in class you know
classrooms got those skinny windows
right and i'm like doing my work and i
remember a head popping in the window
and it was my mom
and my mom and she was like she's just
biting her lips
and i remember the teacher's like mr
heart your mother wants to see you and i
was like don't don't let me go out there
for myself
he's like go ahead mrs hart you excuse
nothing no no please you gotta come out
there
and i remember walking out in that hall
and all i heard us say was you had me
get to work two hours early
but nobody else in the office but me she
beat me all the way home
every bus we got on she hit me had me on
the bus with nobody else on the bus
the train i never i think i got whoop i
may have gotten whooped for three and a
half hours straight and there was
nothing i could say and i was happy
because i made the team and she was like
oh you made the team i made the team
[Applause]